peers clashes with model engine I love
peers
[Music]
parents in the video These critics
saying that it glorifies obesity that
your weight is unhealthy and that by
appearing in the video You're
encouraging people to be overweight and
then once this critic had spoken out a
big backlash against the criticism by
people saying No this is about accepting
all sorts of different shapes and sizes
which is the camp that I'm in as I'm
sure the viewers already know but what
is your view and how have you reacted to
the criticism against you well I mean
fat people exist there's no question
about that but it's it's whether we
should be celebrating a body image which
is medically defined as highly dangerous
and I'll explain why uh if you don't
mind me just going through some stats
here you're 36 years old you're five
foot four you're 380 pounds 27.1 Stone
and your BMI is 64.6 now the BMI ranges
according to the World Health
Organization 18 is underweight uh up to
24 normal weight 25 to 29 overweight 30
to 34 class 1 obesity 35 to 39 Class 2
obesity anything over 40 class 3 obesity
which is morbid obesity a level of
obesity which could very possibly lead
to to early death your BMI is 64.6 so
Mike do you think that Angelina doesn't
know all of them no and the reason I'm
saying it is so that viewers can
understand the debate properly my
argument is this is that when you are
that level of morbid obesity
statistically is it right to put people
like yourself into a pop video
celebrating that kind of weight and I
ask you honestly to be honest with
yourself we've had all this with test
holiday uh she's on the cover of Cosmo
and it's all celebrated there's no
mention of it being a dangerous way
honestly if you were really concerned
about people being obese and and
representing something bad you would
take yourself off the air because you're
not exactly slim yourself well okay I'm
220 pounds I'm six foot one right you're
five foot four and you're 380 pounds so
there is a difference I'm not morbidly
opened but you're still I'm actually
reasonably you're still fast
nowhere near fat and she's just
projecting and not answering the
question this is what happens when the
NPCs the people that are just supposed
to exist cook the fries and go home call
it a life this is what happens when they
get on camera take a close look at him
and and she's calling him fat this is
Tick Tock comments on a [ __ ] News
stream well you might think I'm fat most
views viewers are looking at this thing
is she serious so
entitled to throw the jibes but you're
still fat you being left
me you know not in a pop video am I
extol yourself you're on TV you're on TV
every day so you think that me sitting
here every day you're gonna tell me that
you think just to clarify there is a
comparison between me sitting here now
six foot one 220 instead of answering
questions or dealing in facts they turn
around and they if this was about race
they would call him racist if this was
about sex they would probably misogynist
and and I bet if we watch this long
enough she'll call him a misogynist just
because that's what just to throw it in
there just to throw it in there why not
and you're already calling them all the
names she might also call them racist
and say that you know because X percent
of black women are fat that makes you
now you hate fat now you hate black
women so well for him for her to turn
around and call him fat though this is
what the again name calling name calling
is the answer he shows up with facts
data and asks relatively a polite
question considering she put herself in
this situation
you don't like tequila strong [ __ ]
[ __ ] so oh my God what are you trying
to burn a hole in your throat you're
trying to kill the cancer in your body
with that drink drinking like anything
to drink in weeks I've been a [ __ ]
none it tastes like battery acid all
right let's go I am reflecting and
celebrating a clinically dangerous level
of weight do you think I think that if
you were really concerned about
glorifying obesity you would take
yourself off the air but I'm not obese
maybe she doesn't take herself the air
you know we always talk about the basis
funny interrupting the basement and
that's all you do and we don't see no
comments about me getting interrupted I
said I was sorry get over it move on I
don't see no comments about that
I'm always interrupted go ahead it's
gonna say she went on to the air knowing
that they're going on to talk about her
fatness which I can't even believe she
went on to even talk about that that's
insane but you know she had she probably
came up with her points ahead of time
she knew that this is what he was gonna
say so she can't even think of anything
else that's just her one point when he
said something she just was like her NPC
mine the one point she wrote down she's
like well if you really do care about
fat people you would just take yourself
off the air you think she's gonna say a
different point the whole video she says
it again I guarantee she says if we
could be a fly on the wall she didn't
even come up with that herself one of
her other Fat Friends was like hey you
know what you should say you should say
if you really cared you should take
yourself off the air this is the best
thing that her and her Circle could come
up with this is the best argument
because she definitely talked about it
period you're still fast it's a
statistical medical field you're fat
though I'm not medicated yeah but you
being less this is the point then my
point is okay with great respect you my
body's mass index is not 64.6 which is
24 above the morbid obesity level so you
can you know you can throw it back at me
and that's fine I'm a big boy in many
ways right that's fine right however I
have a serious point I think there is a
trend now with Tess holiday now you of
glamorizing morbid obesity which
actually is dangerous and I I'd say this
for your health as much as anything else
it's like it is a dangerous weight to be
do you accept that well piers
honestly I will tell you I am not
healthy I'm not going to pretend like I
am in perfect health but I am 46 years
old not 36. okay I am eight years
younger than you and and don't look my
age she doesn't look 46 together oh she
looks you know why though
because she has pounds of makeup on and
if I don't know part of that
I put so much fat under your skin it's
impossible to have wrinkles wait how
many pounds did this issue as three a
lot 340 a lot okay if I gained 200
pounds you would never wrinkles I
wouldn't [ __ ] wrinkle anywhere I
would look like a brand new baby like I
just popped out of a giant vjj yeah she
has zero wrinkles but how the [ __ ] you
guys come on
the health problems I have are more age
related than weight related okay I mean
I feel the same way about the size zero
models on cats that's right it's not
about an anti-fat person thing and I
totally could see that I would like to
be a little bit Slimmer a little bit
healthier and fitter right uh I get that
but there is a difference between me and
you and I I would like you to be honest
about this rather than you know doing
lots of press around your Miley Cyrus
video which makes it look like this is
all pretty cool I think the thing is
that what Angelina is saying is this is
not about glamorizing this is about
accepting if we accept it we're going to
create a bigger problem num at the
moment there's obesity is
um a huge a huge problem in terms of
death rates so we can't ignore that fact
and but also you know people say that uh
looking perfect is a problem for for
instance teenagers because all teenagers
think they beat well that's a very good
point but a lot of people think that by
having you know you look utterly perfect
and love Islanders all look utterly
perfectly perfect I have cellular I have
things that I don't like we all do but
what so it's about acceptance of course
all of the different exceptions who is
really unhealthy again the same with
peer saying if we had put someone who
was anorexic on a music video there
would be absolutely I totally agree
that's the point I would make and I
actually think yeah and honestly I think
that is a valid point uh Angelina is
that if they had put you know we went
through that period of what they called
heroin Chic in fashion were these
incredibly skeletal models were put on
covers and catwalks and there was a huge
outcry deemed to be promoting and
propagating an unhealthy body image and
I think the same applies with great
respect to you to models like yourself
and test holiday and so on I'm just
uneasy when it's framed as this is a
glamorous pop video and here you are
here's the cover of Cosmo and here you
are without actually re-emphasizing
constantly that this is a really
dangerous unhealthy weight to be this is
all this man is saying is let's just
look at the fact people with these
weight measurements and you know BMI all
the things he was talking about these
are the things that caught that those
people are at higher risk for heart
failure diabetes cancer you name it and
she's in complete denial of it and
instead turning it on this guy who may
very well die of [ __ ] all those
things before she does but it'll be an
anomaly if he does it'll be unusual this
is crazy that is a really good point
though how them promoting like the real
the real thin people during the 90s was
bad because then girls would starve
themselves to try to look like that so
promoting fat people should be the same
thing yeah exactly and it's bad to
promote the fat people being everywhere
and telling fat people like it's okay
and then they're depressed and then you
go to the doctor and the doctor tells
them to get unfat to not be depressed
and they're like they don't even listen
to my Pro problems you don't listen to
why I came here
you're fat well not even that you're fat
it's that you're eating foods not
everything you eat too good there's a
mind gut connection and everything you
eat affects your brain and how people
don't think that garbage and garbage out
how what you eat affects more than the
fat cells it's connected to your brain
how they don't understand that or even
just even without any scientific
knowledge just make that assumption make
that leap is beyond me but if you're in
this chat and you're fat stop eating
junk food man I don't care who you are
man like I'll tell you as much food
processed food or eat it once a week
once a week dude just cut it out you
know how everyone knows how to not be
fat there's obviously like specific
specific diet stuff you can do but like
for the most part if you just eat
healthy and you go to the gym you walk
you take the stairs just do normal [ __ ]
like that using your body you're not
gonna you're gonna be in better shape
like it's really not that hard you just
live your life as you're meant to be
lived like as it was supposed to be live
yeah right we're actually not supposed
to to be in elevators escalators all the
time take the [ __ ] stairs use your
body if you can't take the stairs
without [ __ ] huffing and puffing
that's a problem dude I think
normalizing it is the problem but
unhealthy people still deserve to see
themselves represented but why would you
want to be represented in a pop video I
don't get it I mean if you want to be
what if you want to be a good uh role
model you could just that's my job well
I do that is my job right but you see my
I I would respect you more with respect
to you if I saw you doing a fitness
campaign were you trying to lose a
hundred pounds rather than appearing in
another video
keep dreaming babe she's dreaming why
well why keep dreaming why wouldn't you
aspire to do that
it's not gonna work it's not gonna work
diets are 95 failure rate why would I do
something that's gonna fail because I
would hope you would want to save your
own life and I would like you to save
your own life you seem a very
charismatic person to me you you you
give it back as well as you take it I
respect all that right but I would not
like you to die of morbid obesity at a
very young age he's kind he's kind he's
being very kind yeah he's a good girl
and I want to gain 200 pounds now so I
hope not my wrinkles keep dreaming babe
she I told you I literally said I called
this out exactly she wouldn't know what
to say if there's a different point than
what her her brain wrote down before the
droids man they're droids I look at some
some of my DMs and Tick Tock comments
and I'm fully convinced that we we live
with NPCs you know the guys at the top
they're gonna do old comments Order 66
Execute order
66. it's like have you you guys ever
seen the SpongeBob movie where everyone
puts the the Chum Bucket hat on and they
become NPCs
[Music]
that's what Society will be I do believe
that Everyone's entitled to different
opinions but the we live in the
SpongeBob movie so not everybody is a
Droid because some people just have
different opinions but in this case I
don't want to call her Droid but I do
want to say that this woman is
completely denying just basic facts in
order to continue her destruct her
self-destructive behavior and in order
to to encourage distracted behavior in
other people this is like a heroin
addict to go back to the what was it
called the I hope some people understood
the order 66 reference no I didn't but
it's so cute
but this girl like this is the same as
going back to that you know heroin Chic
thing encouraging anorexia or bulimia
because I back then I was in a you know
competitive dance ballet worlds and
there were girls that were bullying
I was like dude and I happen to be
skinny it didn't even occur to me to
throw up all the time just force myself
but they did you know and I and I tried
to stop them what do you yeah but [ __ ]
you and also with diets being 19 I'm 46
I might not worried about not living a
full life I'm you know I've already
lived a lot of Life trust me and if I
were to die tomorrow I wouldn't regret
it but are you happy because what a
selfish [ __ ] you might if you have kids
and stuff you have people that love you
and you're just like oh she's got kids I
like cheeseburgers I like cheeseburgers
I don't need to live half of my life
what are you gonna do like what kind of
what kind of thought process is that I
like cigarettes I'm just gonna die at 30
I mean look I lived life hey 100 years
ago they live till 30. what are you
gonna do but it's not regard not happy
in regards to other things that aren't
related to my weight stop it okay all
right look it's an interesting debate
and I know your view is very different
to mine right yes totally you don't
think yes there's anything wrong with
this are you would you be happy
appearing in that video would you be
happy with that I think if someone is
like that yeah but she wasn't born like
that she's made her cancer when they
when they cancel when they come to
cancel me that's going to be the first
clip
in front of your mother
my fault you're gross you're disgusting
themselves
you know what okay so I just why
wobbled Pierce Morgan and why he
ultimately left Good Morning Britain
yeah
thank you for those of you defending me
you would yeah say goodbye to Sunday
because I'm murdering him tonight is it
because people are massively oh stop it
pause it I got [ __ ] to say so he he
ended up leaving Good Morning Britain
after he criticized Meghan Markle for
her Oprah interview I just looked it up
because I couldn't remember what it was
controlling it pull yourself together
farts are funny bro they're not that
funny Jesus Christ he he's a he's a
street shooter but do you agree with him
or not and mostly I agree with him I
like this guy and look at the woman next
to him she is completely defending the
fat girl and going well she is here she
is yeah no yeah I don't know her 8 000
calories a day and and say it's it's
women's lib whatever Piers Morgan is
logical and he's interesting and he's
intelligent so I recommend checking out
some of his stuff I don't know him I'm
not getting paid to say this this is not
a paid advertisement for Piers Morgan
we're not allowed to say actually that's
unhealthyisms through very punishing
regimes to be on the front of magazines
I think it's very hard to be holidays
only punishing regime was to eat lots of
food
says could a fat person save you if you
were drowning the answer to that is
probably not and also well they could
not I could not save them if they were
drowning they could just go under you
and just like float you and just float
up flat do fat people float because they
have so much fat everybody floats
so also well yeah people gaining weight
is to get somewhere except for modern
media is not flooded with people who are
hugely overweight yeah of course let me
ask you actually exactly
that are actually out there yeah I tend
to actually here's my thing
it's so small it's so small I I think
Angelina a bit of fat shaming is a good
thing right I think that when people say
to me you put on a bit of Timber mate it
makes me go back and try and lose a bit
of Timber eat a bit less drink a bit
less get on my pellets on buy off we go
right I I need to have people look at me
going Hey Big Boy lose a bit let's work
on it because whenever we mention it on
air as a joke you complain no no that's
it I do that to you because you're the
great virtue signaling we can't say
anything negative about anybody's body
image everyone's perfect I don't agree I
think a bit of fat shaming is a good
thing a healthy thing what do you think
Angelina I think you're wrong I think
that people should be allowed to live
you [ __ ] hypocrite five two minutes
ago you fat shamed him I think you're
wrong I think that people should be
allowed in the room without somebody
come commenting on everything that they
do or what they look like 380 pounds
Nike woman appearing in a Miley Cyrus
videos
good for you [ __ ] please
we're all going to talk about your body
aren't we you know that that's why you
did it
right no I did it to get paid okay
honestly yes good for you she may have
done it to get paid what the Miley Cyrus
thing yeah but she also did it knowing
that people were going to talk about her
body this is earlier in this live stream
where they were talking to that girl in
Vegas who was like I just for me and
this and that and you know any man you
know she's just like a hoe and any man
that cat calls hers wrong but she'll say
she dressed for her and she also knows
that what the result is and then what
the potential result is that she's going
to get cat called and complains about
the cat calling so these broads aren't
as dumb as they pretend to be as they go
oh it's so wrong how could you call me
fat when I'm dancing in a video well you
also went up you also went on the news
knowing that they're not talking to you
about your dancing ability they're
talking to you about your weight yeah so
we got a super chat this whole fat is
good movement it's simply about money
Industries have been neglecting this
demographic for a long time and in
turning missing out on Millions if not
billions of dollars now they're waking
up for lost time and dollars and pushing
it hard yep that makes perfect sense
thank you for the Super Chat dude it
means a lot gazio I know how to say name
now yeah they're just tapping into a new
market making a bunch of friggin money
if these people are fat they need more
medicines they're taking their
antidepressants they're easier to
control it makes sense why you'd want
people fat and compliant
bottom line don't take anybody's
[ __ ] they're feeding this [ __ ]
and they're feeding this to young people
do not accept it and if you have young
people in your life yourself your
friends your nieces and nephews your own
children whoever it is around you do not
don't try to force logic down their
throats but try to sprinkle seeds of
logic so that they can come to it
themselves because the harder you push
the more they're going to resist the
thing is is that they push it onto us
it's the same thing with like the lgbtq
they go and then they they tell our kids
that like boys can be girls so then
they're gonna go telling everyone like
yeah it's okay to be fat like yeah we
should be fat that's what we're saying
is like it's not okay to push that being
fat is good and okay because it's not
you're gonna it's unhealthy we love
J-Rock there's a picture of Jay Rock in
our house next to Jesus as a real estate
[Music]